ja das war ein sehr kurzes statement von
herrn röcke zu seinem parteiausschluss
verfahren das heute gegen ihn
beschlossen wurde
das gibt uns jetzt gelegenheit zur
erneuten für scheiben york neunten einer
der sprecher der asg und zugeschaltet
aus stuttgart und tag erneuten ermorden
erklären sie uns ihre haltung der dinge
waren sie für oder gegen den
parteiausschluss von herrn höcker ich
war
ich war einer von denjenigen die gegen
die eröffnung des verfahrens bestimmt
haben
und es gab dafür zwei maßgebliche gründe
der eine grund liegt darin dass ich das
verfahren wird für wenig aussichtsreich
halte weil das eine das ist die
schärfste stufe das schärfste schwert
das deutsche partei recht hat und ich
will den tatbestand hier nicht als
erfüllt an insofern glaube ich nicht
dass es erfolgreich verlaufen wird
das zweite ist dass ich auch inhaltlich
wenig begründet hatte ewe zwar die
dritte rede von jörn röcke die hier
ursächlich für die einhaltung dieses
verfahren selbst als sehr kritisch an
sowohl in inhaltlichen passagen als auch
im vierer rede
ich halte es aber nicht für ausreichend
um ein parteiausschlussverfahren
einzuleiten
das geht mir als maßnahmen schlicht zu
weit und verfügen habe ich doch dagegen
votiert aber damit zeichnet ja jemand
das holocaust mahnmal als mahnmal der
schande wie weit muss man dennoch gehen
dass sie dafür zu seinem
parteischädigend fänden aber
entschuldigung aber das
holocaust-mahnmal in berlin ist ein
denkmal der schande weil es das
dunkelste kapitel deutscher geschichte
beleuchtet das ist so bei einem korrekte
aussage weil es tatsächlich ein denkmal
der deutschen stande ist nämlich der
untaten die im namen der nazi
vergangenheit meint ihrer meinung nach
das wäre hätte das in der neutralität
gemeint hat die sie uns das jetzt
erklären
das ist mein verständnis und womöglich
am nächsten tag aufgedrückt hat die
formulierung kann man auf zwei arten und
pfeifen interpretieren die interpret für
interpretation wie die mir in den sinn
kam als ich diese rede mir angeschaut
hat das habe ich zunächst mal getan
bevor ich mich überhaupt dazu geäußert
habe da haben sich andere nicht
angehalten haben bevor
sich geäußert ich habe zunächst die rede
angeschaut ich habe auf den winter
gesprochen und damit an ein urteil
gebildet und habe auf basis dieses
urteils gesagt ich finde das internet
auch gesagt diese rede als reichlich
misslungen und gibt etliche passagen an
denen ich mich stören
aber ich sehe darin keine position die
außerhalb dessen liegen was dafür
akzeptieren können es heißt also auch
jemand wie er hörte er auch dann gehen
wir mal weg von dieser rede unumwunden
ja gerne provoziert platz wie in der afg
ja definitiv
jetzt hat er selber gerade davon
gesprochen dass dieses
parteiausschlussverfahren das heute
beschlossen wurde ja eben partei spalten
könnte diesen wieder verboten
das ist genau meine frau ich bin in
großer sorge um die einheit der partei
schaffe ich kann die die andere position
verstehen ich kann verstehen dass man
sagt diese rede hat der partei
tendenziell ihrem ansehen in der
öffentlichkeit geschadet dass sich schon
auf das muss man vielleicht ein stück
weit einfach aushalten und wollte dann
daran arbeiten dass wir künftig nicht
mehr passiert darüber habe ich mit
hertha gesprochen von dem ich ein gutes
verhältnis habe und wir können das
vertrauen voll und offen miteinander
sprechen eine andere geschichte ist aber
nach außen partei abscheu rauszufahren
ableitet das kann dann eben passieren
dass das in der tat spalterische
tendenzen in meiner partei auslöst und
ich will mich in meiner rolle dazu
aufgerufen genau das zu verhindern darum
wende ich mich auch dagegen und wurde
ich mich hier nicht habe durchsetzen
können in dieser abstimmung im
bundesvorstand für den anderen
abstimmungen anders und müssen wir
schauen was aus diesem verfahren wird
wir werden das verfahren jetzt haben was
beschlossen wurde dass ich auch mit
fragen trage ich auch mit verständlichen
demokratischer beschluss des
bundesvorstandes
ich vermute dass es im sande verlaufen
wird dergestalt dass das schiedsgericht
thüringen oder später vielleicht das
bundesschiedsgericht wie handy
anschließen wird aber ich kann hier
natürlich nicht produzieren macht die
partei juristen dazu sagen das ist auch
nicht meine aufgabe das zu tun hätten ja
andere möglichkeiten gehabt auch ein
verfahren gegen herrn hüppe oder
ähnliches dabei nichts konkret
aufgekommen vielleicht hätte man vorher
vielleicht mehr auf maßnahmen bringen
konnten irgendwie müssen irgendwie zu
strafen glauben sie dass das leichten
versäumnis bestanden hat ist es so dafür
werden bewertungs rechtlich betrachten
dass verschiedene maßnahmen gibt die
drastische maßnahme wäre die eine
maßregelung einen ordnungsruf ist oder
wir können und die schärfste regelung im
als ordnungsmaßnahme mit dem das
parteiausschlussverfahren mit einer mit
einer abmahnung hätte ich mich durchaus
anfreunden können ich hatte wenig
zwingend notwendig aber das fertig für
akzeptabel gehalten weil in der tat an
der rede manche verbund wert war
welche auch so habe ich jetzt dann eben
vom schärfsten schwert gegriffen worden
dass das ausschlussverfahren
und das ist in meinem urteil dann macht
jeder sein eingefordert haben in meinem
urteil ist das unangemessen scharf und
deswegen habe ich da mit nein votiert
aber eher für frauke petry hat gesagt es
sei ausreichend juristisch geprüft war
den trauen sie also nicht
ich kenne diese euro die juristische
prüfung die war grundlage der heutigen
forschung telefonkonferenz
mich hat das nicht überzeugt
meinen kollegen thailand zum beispiel
hat das auch nicht überzeugt und noch
zwei weitere auch nicht das macht man so
oder so wenig glaube dass das nicht
hinlänglich also in ähnlich sein wird um
wir auswahlverfahren wirklich einmal
dieser sich den erfolgreichen abschluss
zu führen
ich mag mich dass ich bin kein jurist
und wie gesagt ich will den juristen
auch nicht vorgreifen
mich hat es mich darüber folgt wir haben
heute war dass einer von beiden
von zwei bundes speichern der afg zu
geschafft aus stuttgart ganz herzlichen
dank
ich danke ihnen